[Musique]
non
tom tu l as toujours un grand bonnet
très pointu on ne voit pas ses yeux une
grosse barbe et un gros menée puisque
sert de normand fête de la forêt un
petit esprit protecteur
j'ai des chutes de tissus je les
assemble un peu comme je peux et je les
roule sur elle-même pour obtenir un
petit boudin que je vais pouvoir mettre
à l'intérieur du corps de mon utah voilà
si je voulais bien serré et je tiens
pendant quelques secondes pour que ça
lui résiste
[Musique]
on essaie avec ses doigts de former une
petite boule avec un petit peu de
matière on prélève voyez j'ai pris
l'équivalent d'une noix avec quelques
coups d'aiguillé
je fixe la matière voyez comme ça ça ne
va plus bouger je ne vis que la barbe ne
soit soit un petit peu aléatoires donc
je défais les mèches
voilà j'ai disposé malène de façon
aléatoire pour assembler le petit bonnet
on coud au poing droit tout simple et
mais bord à bord les deux côtés du
triangle
et puis on n'a plus qu'à faire une
piqûre droite au bord on va enfiler le
bonnet sur notre petit homme te et il ne
nous reste plus qu à coudre le nez au
milieu du chapeau et donc on a réalisé
notre petit couple de tonte eux
[Musique]